peter you went and visited with mike
mccarthy spent some time talking to him
before the hiring cycle started he was
on the list for four of the five
vacancies
what do you think he said to get jerry
jones to as i was told basically fall in
love at first sight with mccarthy
i believe he said two things i'm not the
same coach
who got fired 13 months ago
and here are the ways that i'm different
here are the ways that i'm better and i
think he went over those ways i think he
he showed them
whether it be
in some sort of handout or in some deck
i think he showed them and talked about
some of the ways that he would modernize
for instance
he would have a staff
of both analytics
video people devoted to football
research
that would be in if it if he could do it
his way 14 people
now there's not a lot of teams in the
nfl there are some that that are nutty
about analytics
but i think there are not a lot of
people that have 14 people in that
department and i think that would
surprise people about mike mccarthy the
one other thing
i think
and i don't know this at all i don't
know that he did the first thing you ask
what i think is what i think he did but
i also think he said
that i believe that i can make dak press
got a little bit better
and
the one thing that mike mccarthy does
that he's a real football nerd about
is the exact right way to do a pass drop
the exact right way to do mechanics in
and out of the pocket
and i think he convinced jerry and
steven jones that i can sharpen up dak
prescott and make him better i got two
quick points to make first todd archer
of espn.com has a story that looks into
the eight-day odyssey that ended the
season with jason garrett as the coach
and seven days later he's gone one day
after that mccarthy's in a high-ranking
unnamed source with the cowboys
presumably somebody with the last name
jones told archer that the cow if the
cowboys had not been overwhelmed by mike
mccarthy or any other candidates there
was a chance jason garrett could have
returned his coach which explains why
they kept the bird in the hand while
they looked for the two in the bush
peter that's why they didn't fire jason
garrett last week they wanted to
interview some people and make sure that
they were actually getting an upgrade
before they choose the devil they don't
know over the devil they did know and
one other point i want to make about
mccarthy and his final years in green
bay when he was fired mark murphy the
ceo of the packers used a very important
word during the press conference
explaining why they did what they did
complacency a sense of complacency had
set into the organization peter that's
what happens to an nfl team that doesn't
have an owner in the building i mean the
packers don't have an owner at all
now
mccarthy's at the other extreme the
owner isn't just in the building the
owner's going to be up his butt the
owner is going to be sorry the owner is
going to be around all the time
there's not going to be any complacency
from mike mccarthy in dallas
i think it's easy to say that jason
garrett could have come back as head
coach
i think there's absolutely unequivocally
no way that would have happened i you
know talk about talk about throwing that
out to your fans into the media again
people would have gone nuts i just don't
think that would happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports